I think crowdfunding is a wonderful
democratization of capital it allows
them any more people to come into the
marketplace here 24 when companies had
to market themselves in closed networks
that were presented as accredited
investors by people they knew and had to
go around we have one-on-one or in
groups of people to promote your company
and try to raise capital today on the
platforms for crowdfunding really opens
it up to anyone that can qualify as an
accredited investor to really see all
kinds of deal flow so that's a good
thing I think what we need to look at is
as we develop this marketplace most of
it is early seed stage funding that is
going on so what is the next level what
is this where does this play in the food
chain of capital raising and right now
it is mostly at the seed stage and I
think that one of the wonderful
questions we'll explore at exponential
finances what are the next stage is how
to venture funders look at the crowd
funding group of people is shareholders
in the company will crowdfunding go to
the next level and raised significantly
more and really challenged some of the
venture firms in funding companies
unlikely that it would be at the
twenty-five fifty and a hundred million
dollar levels but it certainly could be
at the five million dollar level where a
lot of early-stage venture firms are
today I think that angel investing clubs
which are very popular now around the
country and I know for those that are
investing in in women we have you know
Belle capital and golden seeds and
thirty seven angels and they're all over
the country but how do they feel I think
there's a little feel of threatening
their marketplace by crowdfunding and so
I think there are a lot of questions
about how companies present themselves
but i do think bottom line it is a
democratization of capital and it'll
work its way out in the marketplace and
it'll be a mature
way of raising fund as we go forward so
I think it's a very exciting time in the
marketplace and this I think is going to
loosen up some of the capital that is
really in the hands of individuals
around the country who haven't had the
opportunity to really see a good deal
flow and they are going to be able to
access it now if they want to be active
on any of these platforms raising
funding